[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait des années qu'on parle de
consigner les bouteilles d'eau au québec
et pourtant il ne se passe rien imaginez
thomas mulcair ministre de
l'environnement proposé l'idée en 2005
david heurtel a évoqué et c'est
maintenant au tour d'isabelle me lançant
j'ai actuellement dans les cartons cette
possibilité là on consomme près deux
milliards de bouteilles d'eau chaque
année au québec et plus de la moitié se
retrouvent dans la nature
beaucoup ne finissent pas dans le bac de
récupération parce qu'elles sont
consommés à l'extérieur de la maison
on est les seuls au canada avec
l'ontario où le mento band pas avoir de
consignes sur les bouteilles d'eau dans
les autres provinces un dépôt de 5 à 10
ans vous ayant tout ou en partie
remboursé quand vous rapporter la
bouteille bon là il passé si c'est
qu'une fois que vous aurez terminé de
boire votre bouteille d'eau vous devrez
la portée par exemple dans une épicerie
mais les détaillants disent qu'ils n'ont
pas de place dans leurs magasins
puis après il ya les frais de
manutention et les centres de tri qui ne
sont pas tous en mesure de produire des
ballots de plastique d'assez bonne
qualité pour les recycleurs je veux que
la chaîne soit complète quand je pourrai
annoncer quelque chose
le parti québécois pensent plutôt qu'il
faut éliminer progressivement la vente
du bouteilles d'eau au québec la
coalition avenir québec ne souhaite pas
élargir la consigne mais plutôt
moderniser nos centres de tri et tendre
vers le résidus ultimes et québec
solidaire promet d'instaurer une
consigne sur les bouteilles et autres
récipients de verre de plastique et
d'aluminium et de majorer le taux des
consignes pour qu'elle devienne un mini
site est il réel vous connaissez
l'expression je vais le croire quand je
vais le voir bah c'est pas mal ce que
beaucoup disent avec la modernisation de
la consigne
[Musique]